everyone and welcome to today's live
webinar a workflow for crisper cast 9
high throughput arrayed screaming with
synthetic crispr RNA I am Marin mayor
growth of GE healthcare and I'll be the
moderator for today's broadcast this
webinar is presented by lab roots and
sponsored by GE healthcare GE healthcare
continues to be an innovator in the
field of gene editing and CRISPR cast
nine research launching the very first
synthetic CRISPR caffeine solution and
now offering one of the most
comprehensive gene editing portfolios in
the industry
ge remains focused to develop effective
tools for the greater research community
for more information about GES CRISPR
cast 9 solutions please visit WWE
can be submitted anytime during the
event by typing them in the Q&A box
which can be found by clicking on the
green Q&A button at the lower left of
the presentation window we will answer
as many questions as we can all
questions not answered during today's
events will receive an email response
from one of our technical support
scientists the presentation window can
be enlarged by clicking on the screen
icon in the lower right hand corner if
you experience any technical problems
viewing or hearing this presentation
please click on the support button at
the top right of the presentation window
or submit the problem through the green
Q&A button this webinar has been
approved for continuing educational
credits please click on the C e button
at the bottom left corner and follow the
process to receive these credits I would
now like to introduce today's speaker
Louise Baskin senior product manager for
GE Healthcare Lewis joined dharmic on
RNA technologies in 2005 since then she
has led the development and commercial
launch of multiple genome-wide si RNA
and micro RNA product lines currently
she is responsible for developing and
expanding the dharmic on editor genome
engineering portfolio which you will be
hearing more about today I will now turn
it over to Louise for the presentation
great Thank You Maren good morning and
good afternoon everyone thank you for
joining us I'm going to be speaking
today about high throughput arrayed
screening with synthetic crispr RNA
libraries so just as a quick review of
the topics I'm going to cover I will
start with a brief overview of
loss-of-function screening and then talk
through the recommendations and methods
for carrying out a successful CRISPR
cast nine screen using arrayed synthetic
crispr RNA I'll then go through an
example of how this can be applied for
the purpose of RNA I hit validation and
lastly I'll show you some results in
various high content assays with a sneak
peek into a screen that we're currently
working on and then I'll close with the
review of the tools that are available
for you to do an arrayed CRISPR screen
of your own now most of the time when
you think about loss-of-function screens
where we knock down or decrease a genes
expression to uncover its function our
minds tend to go to our nai screens the
use of arrayed SI RNA or pooled shrna
reagents to carry this out has become
really very mainstream over the past 10
years in short an s RNA is delivered
into the cell where endogenous RNA
interference machinery uses that s RNA
to identify and degrade a particular
messenger RNA thereby decreasing its
expression but now that Chris Burke has
nine tools are becoming more and more
prevalent in these loss-of-function
workflows it makes sense to utilize them
also in these larger screening
situations now as a reminder
Christopher cast nine works through a
very different pathway and requires not
just an RNA a guide RNA to specifically
target a particular gene but also
requires the introduction or expression
of a caste nine nucleus and then these
two components work together to target
and cleave the gene at the DNA level
once the caste nine nucleus creates a
double strand break the cells own DNA
repair mechanism kicks in non-homologous
end joining or an A TJ typically result
in slightly imperfect repair where this
site of cleavage will have mutations due
to insertions and deletions or in Dells
for short so when you're doing a gene
knockout experiment the desired end
result is an invalid at results in a
mutation that is sufficient to render
the resulting protein useless like a
frameshift or some premature termination
now while there are other repair
pathways possible for the purposes of
today's topic we'll only be covering
results of non-homologous end joining to
result then in a knock out of the target
protein now even though the CRISPR caste
9 tools are only a few years old they
have already been numerous screening
publications including whole genome
screens but to date all of these studies
have utilized lentiviral single guide
RNA pools as opposed to today's topic of
arrayed crispr RNA libraries now I'm not
going to do a deep dive into the
differences between pooled and arrayed
screens much like choosing between RNA I
and CRISPR the choice between pools and
arrays screening may depend on tools you
already have at your disposal the
experimental system you're using and the
biological question you're asking but
just in short pooled screens which are
carried out with lentiviral reagents
expressing an SH RNA or a single guide
RNA generally require less
infrastructure as they are performed in
large culture dishes and because you're
using lentiviral transduction these can
also be carried out in difficult to
transpile whereas a raid screens may
require high throughput equipment if the
library has hundreds or thousands of
genes and potentially multiple reagents
per gene and generally these are used
with cells that are amenable to
transfection but while there is a
trade-off in the amount of handling
required there's also a trade-off in the
types of assays that can be used pooled
screens require a method for selection
of a phenotype that will either enrich
or deplete a population of cells under
the experimental conditions but in
contrast there's really no limitation on
the types of assays that can be used in
a raid screens so this is just a more
visual demonstration of what I'm talking
about
although arrayed screens will support
very straightforward phenotypes like
viability and drug resistance they also
expand the types of experimental
questions that can be addressed into
more visual cell based assays so these
sample images on the slide are taken
from an article on high-throughput RNAi
eye screening and they really represent
a lot of high content assays like
translocation of tagged proteins
analysis of nuclei size and shape
morphological changes up and down
regulation or re localization of a
protein and there's really more examples
in what I can name here but the point
being is there there are opportunities
for multi parametric and very complex
biological questions to be addressed
when you're working in a one gene per
well format
so then in bringing this concept back to
the available screening tools the most
practical tool for investigation of
hundreds or thousands of gene targets in
an arrayed format is a synthetic crisper
and tracer RNA so this kind of dual RNA
system now you may know that Dharma Khan
products are based on high throughput
high quality RNA synthesis so it was a
very natural evolution for us to develop
our gene editing platform with synthetic
RNA as the basis so the editor synthetic
crispr RNA is modeled after the
naturally occurring dual RNA system
which includes the target specific
crispr RNA which we'll couple then with
the tracer RNA which is the longer RNA
that together forms a complex to
activate to the cast nine nucleus that
directs the cleavage of the genomic DNA
target so just a little bit more about
the editor synthetic platform dharma
Khan was the first to employ the
synthetic dual RNA approach for CRISPR
cast nine guide RNAs when we launched
these editor products in 2014 not only
does it mimic the natural bacterial
system it's also much more practical for
chemical synthesis and now you might say
well why does it matter - for using
synthetic when there's so many sources
for expression plasmid or in-vitro
generation of guide RNAs that are
available well first the editor RNAs
arrive ready to use having undergone
full quality control there are no
cloning steps no requirement for
sequence verification no purification or
quantitation that needs to be done
before used these these hands-on steps
might be fine if you're working only
with a few genes but for dozens or
hundreds of plates you're at very high
risk of introducing variation and some
of that perceived cost savings will
really start to dwindle when you take
into account the consumables and the
hands-on time that would be required
there are also no design steps required
with editor the products are available
pre-designed with
algorithm that selects for functional
and specific target sites because the
system is RNA based it's fully transient
there's no DNA components that might
integrate into your cells giving you
less chance of off target effects from
from any ongoing expression and these
small RNAs are also much less toxic than
in vitro transcribed RNAs and the much
easier to transect than plasmid DNA and
since the crisper RNA is amenable to
high-throughput synthesis as I mentioned
before we can very easily support
applications like a raid screening that
require hundreds or thousands of unique
CRISPR RNAs now without doing a deep
dive into the editor algorithm I do just
want to show you a quick couple pieces
of data that illustrate the rationale
behind it and why algorithm designed
crispr RNA is important so using a
functional knockout system generating
data from over 1100 CRISPR RNAs
across ten genes one of those genes is
shown here we identified a set of rules
to select the most functional designs
not just the potential creation of
indels now I'll be discussing the
details of the assay in a moment but for
now just know that in this graph the
vertical axis represents functionality
so low to high and the x-axis is every
possible crispr RNA for every pam in
this genes coding region so the
variability that you see of the
functionality along the coding region
really illustrates the importance of not
just selecting a guide RNA in an early
exon I've listed a few examples of the
selection criteria we examine and were
found to be important and then all of
these functionality rules have since
been validated in multiple systems and
have been incorporated into our
algorithm now here's one of our
validation experiments where we turned
to next-gen sequencing to detect
insertions deletions and mutations at
the CRISPR cut site for CRISPR RNAs with
either the top 10
functionality scores for ten different
genes or for the lowest ten
functionality scores across those same
ten genes now although this isn't
functional phenotypic data we do know
that protein knockouts that arise from
CRISPR casts nine gene editing must be
due to an end L therefore we expected
that our algorithm would demonstrate
differences in the percent in Bell
formation for crisp RNAs with either
high or low functional scores and what
we found is that for high-scoring
crispers 93% had greater than 40% in
Bell formation as you see in the upper
graph while only 33% of the low scoring
CRISPR RNAs were able to reach that 40%
editing efficiency so really
demonstrating that crispers with high
functionality scores have higher overall
in Bell formation efficiency
okay so I've introduced the synthetic
crispr RNA system and the editor
algorithm for functional designs so now
let's talk about actually how you'd go
about doing an arrayed screen with these
tools so the four primary workflow
considerations I will address today are
here on the screen first is selection of
the source of the cast Knight nuclease
second is optimization of delivery or
expression of the cast mining third is
optimization of the CRISPR tracer
delivery and then lastly optimization of
assay conditions so you'll probably have
noticed that the word optimize appears
quite often in this list of
considerations and this relation should
come as no surprise so for anyone who's
done Si RNA screens you'll know that
nearly every cell in the well can be
transfected and will achieve 70 to 90
percent target knockdown
so this is really good penetrance and it
makes it relatively straightforward to
call something a hit with CRISPR cast 9
given that there are 2 required
components the Cassadine nucleus and the
guide RNA depending on conditions you
may get anywhere from 25 to 75 percent
of cells being edited and as those not
all edits will lead to a functional
knockout so we certainly hear concerns
that this potentially lower
penetrance could delay adopting arrayed
CRISPR screening because in a in a rate
format since in a high throughput
setting there is no opportunity to do
enrichment of the edited cells that's
why it's really important to optimize
delivery of both the CRISPR components
expression of the caste 9 and making
sure that you're working with guide RNAs
that give you efficient functional knock
out the quantitative reporter assay are
referred to earlier when showing you the
the work we did with algorithm
development is a functional readout
involving disruption of proteasome
function we've used this assay
extensively with Si RNA so we had a very
good idea of signal strength and and
good positive control genes to work with
so we used an engineered you to OS cell
line that has a mutant ubiquitin fused
to egfp such that when the proteasome
pathway is functional the ubiquitin gets
degraded and there is no GFP signal
however when the proteasome function is
disrupted either by knock out or knock
down of proteasome components we get an
accumulation of gfp and then we get a
signal we've used this assay for a few
different gene knockout studies and
working with the CRISPR components but
before carrying out a much larger screen
we knew we had a bit more optimisation
to do so let's start by going through my
list beginning with how we selected a
source of the cast 9 nucleus so there
are many reagents available for gene
editing using CRISPR cast 9 again which
what's required is the cast 9 nucleus
and a guide RNA so for the guide RNA
there's a variety of reagents that can
be used but as I've already discussed
we're going to be talking about today
the synthetic CRISPR and trace or RNA
approach so now it comes down to the
cash 9 test 9 nucleus can be delivered
as Lenti viral particles expressed from
a DNA plasmid or directly delivered as a
protein or M
but in the context of screening rather
than just doing a few experiments you
have to consider which source is going
to give you the highest consistency
across wells especially over a period of
time while keeping in mind that Co
transfection will introduce a source of
variation you also need to ensure high
expression of the caste 9 since this
will generally correlate with more
efficient target gene cleavage and then
lastly like everything you do with
screening you need to consider the cost
of scale-up
so although caste 9 protein as well as
mRNA demonstrate really good results
when delivered with synthetic guide RNAs
it would probably be cost prohibitive to
use protein when transfecting hundreds
or thousands of wells
so with those caveats in mind we started
by working with stably expressed caste 9
cells using our editor lentiviral caste
9 nuclease demonstrated on the left as
well as testing coach ran section of the
CRISPR tracer RNA with the editor caste
9 expression plasmid Illustrated on the
right now after doing the same
transaction with both systems on five
different days we looked at full change
of our GFP read out in our proteasome
reporter now as you can see on the left
we had much higher fold change and much
better day-to-day consistency when using
the stable caste 9 cell line and then
simply transfecting the synthetic CRISPR
tracer RNA
whereas Co transfection of the caste 9
plasmid with the guide RNA shown on the
right was much less consistent and
really didn't give as effective results
overall in terms of high GFP expression
with this positive control so we went
ahead with the caste 9 expressing cells
so now that we had decided on using
stable expressed caste 9 let's look at
the next step of an optimizing the caste
9 nucleus expression so the basic
workflow we used is illustrated here
transduction of the lentiviral caste 9
nucleus those cells are then treated
with blasts deciding to select those
that are resistant
and therefore expressing caste 9 and
then growing up and expanding that cell
population now we chose to continue with
a mixed population rather than doing
clonal isolation but either method can
be used we have heard from other
screeners that they've isolated clones
grew them up and then assess them for
optimal cutting efficiency the potential
risk could be that there is an
integration effect from where the length
of RL caste 9 integrates into the genome
but that would be diluted out when using
a mixed population in either case it's
just critically important to make sure
you get good caste 9 expression and
that's where the editor lentiviral smart
choice promoter selection comes in so
with the editor length of RL caste 9
you're able to select one of six
different promoters to drive the caste 9
expression now here are some results
showing a promoter optimization study
now in all cases these cells are
expressing caste 9 under the control of
each of the indicated six different
promoters and then the cells were
selected with blasts decidin for at
least 10 days before doing a
transfection of the CRISPR tracer RNA so
here we used one of our assays positive
control genes VCP transfected the
crisper trays are RNA in triplicate into
the cells and then after 72 hours used
t71 mismatch detection FA to quantify
the actual gene editing or in Bell
formation now as you can see in the
calculated relative frequency of gene
editing we got optimal cutting when
caste name is being driven by the CAG
promoter the efficiency there was much
higher than with other promoters so from
this experiment hopefully you can see
that this can be a very important step
in maximizing gene editing and we'd
certainly recommend this to anyone who's
developing a caste 9 cell line
now one quick point I do want to make
about mismatch detection assay results
it is generally understood that the
percent endo formation is
underrepresented by as much as 50
percent just due to limitations of the
sensitivity of the enzymes but even with
this limitations it is effective to use
in cases where you need to understand
the relative efficiency differences as
opposed to strictly quantitative so now
that we have identified the best
promoter to drive caste 9 expression in
our stable cell line we need to move on
to the second component of the CRISPR
experiment which is the delivery of the
synthetic CRISPR tracer RNA so using our
caste 9 expressing proteasome reporter
cell line we transfected CRISPR tracer
rnase targeting two different positive
control genes in increasing amounts and
then quantify the editing efficiency by
looking at the percentage of cells
expressing gfp now as you can see we saw
a plateau around 10 nano molar
concentration and we didn't really see
improvement as things went higher so our
general guideline is to work with 25 and
animal or concentration because you
really don't want to be on the low end
of the working range but rather more in
the middle and as with Si RNAi screening
one of the most important aspects of
optimization is the transfection step
you need to make sure you're maximizing
delivery of the RNA while maintaining
cell viability and ideally keeping the
amount of transfection reagent to a
minimum so for all of our experiments
we've worked with the Dharma effect
transduction reagent formulation that
had shown good si RNA delivery results
in these cells generally the conditions
for transfection of s RNA are going to
be closely matched with the best
conditions for CRISPR tracer RNA
delivery
so although the screen results I'll be
showing you later we're done with
forward transfection we
no from our extensive interactions with
screeners and our own experience
screening that reverse transaction is
often preferred so I thought it might be
of interest to show an example of that
here so what you're seeing is our
results of optimisation of reverse
transfection first using a CRISPR tracer
RNAi targeting PPI B where that knockout
should really have no impact on
viability as it's a housekeeping gene so
we use three different cell densities
we'd recommend testing at least two in
your system along with four to five
different amounts of transfection agent
while keeping the CRISPR tracer RNAi
amount constant so the upper image is
looking at the viability of ourselves in
each of these conditions as is often the
case as you increase amounts of
transfection agents you can have a
detrimental effect on cell viability so
the green outlined conditions are those
that we found were best for each cell
density and in the lower image is the
assessment of editing efficiency again
using a DNA mismatch detection assay for
a subset of those corresponding
conditions above it's really not going
to do us any good to have happy viable
cells if we're not also getting good
editing with those conditions but as you
can see the green outlined results again
were very good for both viability and
the in del formation okay so once you
have a set of candidate transfection
conditions the final step is to assess
all of this in the context of your
phenotypic assay now we start working
with a positive control for our proteome
assay when we're doing this step of
optimization through here we're using a
PS mv7 which is a known positive in this
gene excuse me in this system as opposed
to a housekeeping gene like we used for
the transaction optimization so it is
important to test whether those optimal
transfection conditions are also optimal
in the context of your assay so in this
slide I'm actually getting back to the
forward transaction conditions that we
used in our screen here using four
different amounts of the dharma sect for
transfection reagent and
measuring both viability shown by the
blue dots and fold increase of GFP
expression shown by the green bars so by
looking for the conditions that maximize
both we identified the optimal acetate
conditions again outlined in green and
these are the conditions we used moving
forward with the larger screen here's a
closer look at the phenotypic and
editing efficiency data we were able to
achieve with our positive controls
following assay optimization on the left
you see treatment with either a crisper
tracer RNA or an S RNA pool which we'd
run alongside some of these initial
trials just as comparison targeting
either PPI B as a negative control for
our assay or PSM d7 and vc p as positive
controls now as you can see from the GFP
expression the penetrance is really
pretty comparable and certainly robust
enough for positive hit calling of this
phenotype and then on the right you're
seeing the corresponding gel again
looking at mismatch detection indicating
really very gene at very efficient gene
editing for these assay conditions so
here's our final workflow so the first
step is again to generate the cast 9
expressing version of our proteasome
reporter cell line and we did this with
the editor lentiviral cast 9 nucleus and
as i mentioned before we continued with
a mixed cell population but you may
choose to develop and characterize a
clonal cell line so to set up the screen
we plated our cast 9 expressing cells
into our assay plates where they were
allowed to adhere sort of rest and
recover for 24 hours then in a separate
plate containing our CRISPR RNAs so in
the experimental designs as well as
positive and negative controls we added
the tracer RNA and then added the Dharma
spec to transfection reagent now I want
to point out here that there is no
requirement for a heating and cooling
step to anneal the editor crisper and
tracer RNA they will hybridize at room
temperature
in just a few minutes so then once those
RNAs have had a chance to complex with
the transfection reagent about 20
minutes this mixture is then added to
the plated cells and the incubation time
begins for our assay we used a 72 hour
time point which happens to be the same
as what we'd used for an mRNA screen
using the same sa so now just to show
you the slight difference in using
reverse transection instead of forward
transfection you would start by
dispensing the CRISPR RNAs from the
original storage plates into your assay
plates and then add the tracer RNA and
then the Dharma sec transfection reagent
to each well and then after that
20-minute complexing time the cast nine
expressing cells are added to the to
those assay plates and then the
incubation time begins so now well not
all cells are necessarily a minha bolt
to reverse transfection it does save you
time in the workflow and requires less
handling of the rnas and fears the
normalized triplicate results for one of
our eight plates we screened 61 genes
with 10 CRISPR rnas per gene in
triplicate now 10 is more than what we
would recommend now at the time we'd not
yet finalized our guide RNA algorithm we
wanted to make sure that we were getting
enough functional data points but as you
can see when compared to the positive
controls in green and a negative
controls in red we saw very nice
clustering of phenotypes for both
moderate and very strong hits as well as
some genes that were clearly negative in
this assay so following this screen we
felt really confident that working under
optimized conditions the phenotypic
penetrance for the purpose of hit
calling was really sufficient and wasn't
going to require any enrichment of the
edited cells in this screen of the 61
proteasome related genes we used we
found 40 hits which was pretty well
aligned with what we expected from our
prior si RNAi screening results and that
will actually take us into our next
topic
so what I'd like to show you now is a
hit validation study we carried out to
determine whether a raid CRISPR RNAs
could be useful as follow-up to Si RNAi
screen results so this is a data set of
an SI RNA screen we carried out a few
years ago in this same proteasome
reporter cell line this time targeting
over 5,000 genes so shown here is the
egfp fold increased values from the
primary screen where the purple data
points are positive controls and
candidate hits and the blue are negative
controls and genes that were negative in
the assay so our primary screen was run
with both si genome and on target plus
smart pool si RNA reagents and then we
carried out additional confirmation with
all eight individual s RNAs that are
components of the pools so to look at
the use of crispr RNA as a follow-up
tool we selected a subset of our hits as
well as some non hits to analyze with
CRISPR knockout now as you might be able
to tell from the gene list those non
hits were selected because they were
known proteasome related genes but they
were negative in the SI RNA screen so
what we wondered was whether these genes
had some kind of a threshold effect such
that unless they had a hundred-percent
knockout as opposed to a 70 to 80%
knockdown might they still remain
negative in the assay so like with the
CRISPR RNAi screen I just described we
were still in a pre algorithm phase when
doing this work so we were working again
with ten crispr RNA is to target each of
these genes as you'll see in later
slides we now recommend four so in this
screen we ended up working with three
hundred and thirty CRISPR RNAs
targeting these 33 genes now I'm not
going to dig into all of the results but
I do want to show you a few
representative genes that illustrate
what we saw so here's an example with
one of our known positive control genes
BCP where on the Left you'll see that
for all ten RNA I reagents that we use
the SI genome smart pool the for SI
genome individuals be on target plus
smart pool and the on target plus
individuals they all gave a GFP read out
above the hit cutoff point so as
expected a very strong high confidence
hit this was confirmed then by our
crispr RNA results where all ten gave a
similarly strong phenotype now here's an
example of confirmation of an on hit so
this gene was negative in our primary si
RNA screen but it is a known proteasome
component so we put it into our test as
a potential false negative however as
you can see zero out of our ten crispr
RNA Davis of phenotype so we feel pretty
confident that there wasn't a an issue
with a loss-of-function threshold effect
for this gene but instead it just might
not be expressed in the cell line or is
not required in this deadline for the
proteome function that were assessing
then the last example I'll show you was
really kind of a weak RNA I hit that
would you know potentially sit on the
bubble of whether or not we would
proceed with it
so again on the left you'll see that
only three of the ten si RNA reagents
have a phenotype and not even a very
strong phenotype at that but when we
move to the CRISPR validation we had
nine out of ten designs give us a
phenotype so here might be a case of
where the crispr RNA might have rescued
this hit you know kept it on the list a
little bit longer the gene of interest
to do for their studies okay since I'm
not going through every gene I just
wanted to provide a summary of of what
the results look like
so everything in green on the table is a
gene that had concordant phenotypes
between the si RNA and the crispr RNA so
ten of our 16 hits were confirmed and 15
of the 17 non hits were verified as non
hits in this assay now there are
probably a few different ways this can
be interpreted but we really feel that
in general this is a very logical
extension of the RNAi eye screening
workflow so to illustrate that here's a
workflow diagram of the screen that I
just described
so an SI RNAi screen with around 5200
genes was carried out with two smart
pool s RNA reagents purging following
conformation with positive hits we
narrowed down to 26 candidates again
that's where we re screen with any
reagent that gave us a hit in the
primary and we then D convoluted each of
those pools to therefore component
individual srna's giving us eight
additional data points now this use of
multiple s RNA reagents per gene is
really considered best practice to
verify an RNA I phenotype so this then
took us to sixteen potential hits where
we used to cut off of three or more
positive s RNA reagents now at this
point sometimes screeners aren't always
sure what to do next they might find a
small molecule that targets their gene
but those aren't always available so
using CRISPR mediated gene knockout is
really a great method for orthogonal hit
validation since you can get away from
the RNA AI pathway and any of its
potential off targets and really just
look at true loss of your target genes
function so the next thing I'd like to
show you are some results we've gotten
with a number of different assays using
now the four algorithm designed CRISPR
RNAs that are part of our editor library
products which I'll be showing you in a
minute so here are some results from an
April 1 essay which if you're not
familiar is an enzymatic as I'm
measuring caspase 3 & 9 as an indicator
of apoptosis
now even though cell death as a
phenotype doesn't necessarily require in
a rate format one of the most common
questions we get is whether viability
related genes or essential genes like
pol k 1 will give visible cell death in
an arrayed CRISPR workflow for many
people this is a very popular
transfection control for instance so
what you see here in the graph are the
caspase readout levels showing the
expected increase for these 3 genes
which are known to induce apoptosis the
images along the top of the
slide are the well images under the
microscope of the pl k1 results
alongside in on targeting control so as
you can see for all four PL k one wells
so each one representing a different
algorithm designed crispr RNA the cells
are kind of balling up and floating away
and generally very unhappy and most
definitely undergoing apoptosis this
next essay is with a similar set of
genes as we just saw but instead we were
looking at a marker for mitotic index
now these cells were again treated with
the four pre-designed editor CRISPR RNAs
during meiosis and mitosis histone h3 is
specifically phosphorylated so the assay
we're looking at used an antibody for
phospho histone h3 and then visualized
it with the in cell analyzer so the
graph indicates the increase we saw for
that phosphorylated histone h3 with our
negative controls as well as our
positive control genes PL k1 and kis 11
and the images along the top are the
cell images for the kif 11 knockout
wells so the blue stain is the nuclei
and the red is the anti phospho histone
h3 antibody so again four different
designs for kif 11 all showing a very
nice increase in the red stain cells
that indicates the increase in mitotic
index now the last set of images I want
to show you it requires just a little
bit of background on the assay so this
assay is actually part of an ongoing
screen we're doing with genes involved
in the cell cycle so we're using a g1 to
s cell cycle phase marker reporters cell
line these cells have an e GFP reporter
fused to a localization domain of
helicase B and helicase B localization
is dependent on its phosphorylation
state which is cell cycle phase
dependent so as you can see in the
diagram during g1 it's localized in the
nucleus in early S phase it gets
phosphorylated and translocates
to the cytoplasm so this is a really
good example of
a say that absolutely requires a one
welp regime format that can interrogate
genes in this case that may play a role
in this aspect of cell cycle progression
so we're still doing our assay
validation but here are some really nice
results with again our positive control
genes so note that rather than showing
you for crispers per gene I'm showing
you one CRISPR for each of four
different positive control genes so two
things here on the slide the egfp
localization as seen under the
microscope and then the cell cycle
analysis based on that localization as
shown in the pie charts so sort of
working left to right when you compared
to the non targeting control where we
find the majority of cells are in s and
g2 phase you'll see that for cycling a
knockout we result we get a very high
increase in g1 cells due to that genes
known role in blocking g1 to s
transition and then for the next three
genes cyclin b PL k 1 and k 11 which
block mitosis you'll see both from the
pie chart as well as in the cell images
that there's an increase in mitosis
indicated by the nuclear egfp so as I
indicated before this assay is the basis
for a much larger screen we're doing
with our editor cell cycle crispr RNA
library and we'll be talking more about
that as the as time goes on as the
screen is completed so what I've shown
you so far today are a variety of
phenotypic assays that have been
successfully applied with arrayed
synthetic CRISPR screening the
proteasome reporter assay the April 1
and dramatic assay and then two
different high content assays one with
that antibody for phosphorylated histone
h3 and one with that egfp translocation
reporter selling now as you saw under
optimized conditions all of these assays
gave us sufficient penetrance to
evaluate target gene knockout phenotype
in a single well with no enrichment
required and so I really feel that these
demonstrate nicely the potential for
arrayed screening using the editor
synthetic crisper and tracer RNA to RNA
system now lastly before I take
questions I do just want to tell you a
little more about the tools that are
available for supporting all of the
workflows that I've covered today so
first is the cast 9 nucleus we offer
four different formats of cast 9 the one
most discussed today was the lentiviral
cast 9 using a constitutive promoter but
there's also an inducible version
available we've found this to be very
popular with many CRISPR screeners
because they worry about detrimental
effects on their cells by having this
constant presence of the cast 9 so it's
inducible you get the power of stable
expression but it only needs to be
induced and expressed just prior to the
screen for transient expression of cast
9 we offer 2 DNA free options that can
be Co transfected with the synthetic
CRISPR tracer RNA so we offer either
mRNA or cast 9 protein our cast 9
protein has a nuclear localization
signal and is now available at a higher
concentration than where you'll find
elsewhere which can be very advantageous
when you're doing electroporation and
then lastly we also have a cast 9 as a
DNA expression plasmid which has the
same choice of constitutive promoters as
I discussed for the lentiviral cast 9
and you also can choose between a
fluorescent or an antibiotic resistance
marker for when you do need to do a
selection or enrichment of transfected
cells so now we get to the arrayed
libraries themselves the predefined
catalog libraries that are available for
human and mouse are listed here you'll
probably see some very familiar
collections if you're all familiar with
the sRNA libraries and many of these
human libraries are already made and on
the shelf
some of them and including all of the
mouse ones would require a few weeks of
production time and we are currently
working towards building a human
druggable collection which will be
around 7,500 genes when completed
now here's just a few more details on
those catalog libraries so they include
four different Christopher rnase brigene
and they're formatted in a 96-well
plates with the outer columns left open
for your essays specific controls to be
added they're available as 0.1 0.25 or
0.5 nanomoles per well and of course if
you require more material we would
simply provide more replicates at those
amounts and since you will need to add
tracer RNA to each well prior to
transfer
we are offering bulk discounted pricing
on the tracer RNA when you're ordering
crispr RNA libraries now if you're
interested in carrying out Si RNA hit
validation like I showed earlier or
maybe you have your own set of genes you
want to investigate that don't overlap
nicely with a catalog collection we'd
recommend a cherry-pick library so what
you're seeing here is a screen shot of
our online cherry-pick library player
where you can configure your own custom
plates so with this offering you're able
to very easily upload your own gene list
for human or Mouse targets and then add
the pre-designed crispr RNA is targeting
those genes to a custom plate we'd
certainly recommend three to four
crispers per gene but we do have up to
five available in our predefined
collection the minimum order is only
twenty Wells and you're able to add
editor controls to the plate as well as
customize the plate layout however you
like the quantities available per well
will range from 0.1 to tune animals per
well so there's really plenty of options
you know for however many Stella Lions
or however many assays you might be
working with
to support these applications you're
going to find pretty extensive online
resources to help you get started just a
few examples are shown here so one is
the reverse transfection protocol that I
referred to earlier we also have a
little more in-depth application note
describing the optimization of reverse
transaction we also have a technical
manual for doing creation of the stable
Cassadine cell line as well as carrying
out that promoter optimization and if
you happen to be working with transient
cast nine rather than stable expression
we also have guidelines for optimizing
code transfection of the Cassadine mRNA
or caste nine protein with synthetic
guide RNAs and with that I will wrap up
with a quick summary before moving on to
questions today I've shown you that it
is very possible to achieve good loss of
function phenotypes with no requirement
to enrich for edited cells the examples
they're shown with the editor synthetic
crispr RNA we do recommend stable
Cassadine expression to improve
reproducibility in penetrants and to use
the editor algorithm design crisp RNA to
improve the chance of having multiple
designs that give you functional knock
out in this arrayed format i reviewed
data from a raid CRISPR rnase used to
validate hits from an SI RNA screen we
saw a very good concordance across the
data and since si RNA and crisper trace
RNA have very similar to inspection
conditions and in our hand had very
similar assay time points there really
shouldn't be a really high barrier to
entry for this method if you're looking
to adopt a raid CRISPR RNAs and then
lastly I showed you some snapshots of
our positive control genes in multiple
assays including a few high content
assays to really try to demonstrate the
potential applications for a raid
screening with synthetic CRISPR RNAs
that just wouldn't be possible with a
pooled screening approach and with that
I will thank you for your attention I do
want to remind you
to visit our website where you'll find
the products and resources I've talked
about today and now I'll turn it back
over to Marin to start our QA Louise
thank you for that informative
presentation as usual now while we are
getting ready for the Q&A session two
polling questions will appear on your
screen we really appreciate your answers
to these questions so we can follow up
appropriately with you during the
question and answer session I would like
to remind our audience how to submit
questions you can submit questions by
typing them in the Q&A box which can be
found by clicking on the green Q&A
button at the lower left of the
presentation window again we will try to
answer as many questions as we can and
it looks like our first question in the
queue is when you optimize the cast 9
plasmid why didn't you wait 24 hours
before transfecting the guide RNA
instead of code transecting wouldn't it
give you better results oh okay so it
sounds like you're referring to the
method of letting the cast 9 plasmid
kind of getting a head start on being
transcribed and translated into the
protein before adding the CRISPR in
tracer RNA so with code transfection it
is certainly possible that there is some
degradation of the CRISPR tracer going
on while it waits for the plasma to come
a protein that's that's not actually
something we've seen a lot of in our own
hands but that's kind of separate from
what you really need to think about in
the context of doing in a raid screen it
would not really be practical to do two
rounds of transparent and Allah a lot of
different plates you potentially have
some toxicity problems you'll definitely
have inconsistency between wells and
potentially inconsistent expression of
the cast 9 and you're also doubling your
cost
of transparency so really between this
kind of hands-on time and handling as
well as overall efficiency we would
still recommend this table expressed
Cassadine thanks for that clarification
another one of our viewers asks what
about cellular cellular responses to
stable expression of caste 9 isn't it
detrimental to the health of the cells
to constantly have nucleus expressed
that is a yeah it's a great question and
a very very common concern there there
seem to be a very wide range kind of
across the spectrum on this topic in
terms of the level of concern we see or
has been reported I think the best
answer is really that it's going to be
cell type dependent and you are probably
going to be the best judge of whether
caste 9 is causing any changes in
viability or morphology or some other
behavior in our hands the stable caste 9
version of the Utah cell line that I
showed you today continues to grow and
behave very normally but we have heard
from from other folks who are making
caste 9 cell lines that you know for 3
out of the 4 they look fine but for in
the 4th their cells just are starting to
act strange or the morphology is
changing so certainly a concern one way
you can get around this if this is
something that you may observe that you
could use the inducible version of our
lentiviral caste 9 so the nucleus is
only getting turned on just prior to the
guide RNA being presented you know and
then it's time to cut the DNA and then
it's turned off or you can use code
transfection of the transient caste 9
for cost purposes I'd probably recommend
mrna over protein they both give very
good results just for the caveat in mind
that Coach I inspection could induce a
little more variability into the screen
Oh excellent thanks for that let's see
the next question in the queue is what
was the time point used in the mitotic
index assay oh okay I'm just going to
flip through my notes really quick to
make sure I get that right that that
actually brings up another very common
and very good question about time points
[Music]
the the logic might tell you that a cast
nine induced knock out should take
longer because you're working at the DNA
level compared to RNA I where you're
working at the messenger RNA level you
know you're kind of further down in the
expression pathway but we actually see
that most of our assay time points
between RNA I and CRISPR are very
similar I don't necessarily have an
in-depth explanation for that but that
is what we observed and to specifically
answer your question for the mitotic
index si that was a 48-hour time point
so post transparent of the crisp RNA was
when that data was collected very good
very good
um another question from one of our
viewers is how much do the crispr RNA
libraries cost okay I didn't know we
were going to go for cost questions but
all right no it's okay um I am NOT
trying to dodge it but I will have to
say it varies right depending on how
many genes are in the library and
whether you get a small quantity or a
large quantity per well obviously that's
going to vary I think that the easiest
way to answer is that we've aligned the
pricing of the libraries very closely
with the price for a non-target plus set
of 4s RNA library so for on target plus
s RNAs is very close to the price we're
offering for for editor CRISPR RNAs
the one thing it would need to keep in
mind is that you would still need to buy
the tracer RNA but generally the you
know it's going to depend on the the
number of genes but we have like I said
aligned it very closely to our
specificity enhanced sRNA library prices
thank you let's see the next question is
how many screens can I complete with one
crispr RNA library good question it is
also going to be dependent on how much
you order right so how much / well there
is a calculator on our website in the
tools and calculators section that can
kind of help you determine this but I'll
give you sort of one method as a rule of
thumb for the smallest size that we
offer which is point one animal per well
that is enough material to carry out 40
screens when you're working at our
recommended point two five nano molar in
a 96-well reaction so that obviously
doesn't take into account you know
pipetting loss or anything but kind of a
realist I'm working at point two five
nano molar in a 100 microliters you can
get 40 screens with point one animal Oh
excellent
thanks for that response and now I'm
being told that we are getting close to
the top of the hour so it looks like we
have time for just one more question let
me see it is is it also valid to use SI
rnase to validate CRISPR cast nine
screen hits oh okay yeah great question
so but what I showed you was using
CRISPR to validate si RNA so then you
know obviously people starting with
CRISPR screens might say well how do I
validate so obviously you'd still want
to follow kind of the same best practice
of using multiple reagents you know per
gene to make sure there isn't some
unique aspect of those crispers that
give you the phenotype but I think it
would be perfectly valid that the
reverse would be true that that knock
down could serve as a validation method
for knock out
I mean it's potentially assay dependent
but I think it's a perfectly logical
place to start
thank you thank you and again thank you
to our audience for all the great
questions and Louise for your answers if
you have submitted a question through
the Q&A button and it was not answered
someone from our technical support team
will respond to you via email if you
have further questions that you did not
submit during this broadcast please
email them to TF thermicon at GE comm
and now on behalf of GE healthcare we
would like to thank lab roots for making
today's educational webcast possible and
this webcast will be available for
on-demand viewing through December of
2016 you will receive an email from lab
roots alerting you when this webcast
will be available for replay we invite
you to forward that announcement to your
colleagues who may have missed today's
live event see you next time goodbye